former Fox News anchor gretchen carlson
is credited with starting a conversation
about sexual harassment and paving the
way for accusers of Hollywood mogul
Harvey Weinstein to speak out the former
Miss America became the face of
workplace harassment last year when she
sued Roger Ailes the founder and
chairman of Fox News her lawsuit claims
that Ailes fired her after she refused
his sexual advances months later Carlson
reached a 20 million dollar settlement
Fox News parent company 21st Century Fox
the company also issued her a public
apology now Ailes denied the claims
before his death in May now Carlson is
an advocate for workplace equality she
was named one of Time Magazine's 100
most influential people in the world for
2017 Carlson has a new book called be
fierce stop harassment and take your
power back she shares a playbook for
women who want to speak out gretchen
carlson worked at CBS News from 2000 to
2005 and she joins us now good morning
welcome back it's so great to be back
although you're in this bright new shiny
studio across the street from where I
used to be yeah I hate to see all three
of you let me ask you you and I have
spoken over the past year you've you
sued one of the most powerful men in
television what made you come forward
what courage is a building process it's
not a light switch that you just turn on
overnight and I think that's really
important especially with this issue
because women are labeled troublemakers
the B word and nothing good they're not
believed when they come forward so it
takes immense courage
it's an excruciating choice but for me I
realized that my career my American
dream of 27 years of hard work that it
was going to come to an end and it
wasn't my choice and I decided that I
had to speak up if I didn't who was
going to do it and I didn't want my
children to face the same indignities
that I had faced you also you also say
that many women any woman who was spoken
up and it's not just TV news you said it
crosses all all kinds of businesses
where this is an issue but you point out
in your book that any woman who has
spoken up is no longer in her chosen
career I thought that was very
interesting and surprising Disney that's
shocking and horrifying yes it's an
equal opportunity epidemic I started
hearing from thousands of women after my
broke Gale and they were waitresses they
were bankers they were accountants
lighter teachers they were flight
attendants many of whom have thanked me
over the last year because they have all
faced this pervasive issue this is a
silent epidemic in their conduct the
perpetrators still in place so they're
still in place because we have chosen as
a culture to silence the victims either
with settlements where you're gagged
from ever saying what happened to you or
in forced arbitration which is a part of
employment contracts now and here's the
key it's secret so these are the ways in
which we've chosen to resolve sexual
harassment in our country and we need to
change explain that for everyone who
doesn't know these arbitration which all
of us sign contracts like that in our
profession as well which means what so
pervasive and employment contracts now a
clause that means that you're giving up
your Seventh Amendment right when you
sign it to go to an open jury process
listen when we start new jobs none of us
expect to get into disputes I know I
didn't right but if you do it's going to
be resolved through arbitration but
here's the key it's secret you can never
tell anyone what you're doing no one
will ever know about it 20% of the time
only the employee wins that much yeah
you say silence is the most powerful
weapon of the harasser
because guess what happens in Gail the
woman gets fired she never goes back to
her chosen career and the harasser is
left in the workplace to continue
harassing which is the case of your
settlements well so the case with my
settlement is that I can continue to
talk about this issue which I've been
doing so much work on it for 15 months I
just can't tell you the nitty-gritty
details but you can look at it online
when a complaint is when you spoke out
some of your Fox News colleagues like
Sean Hannity britt hume jean pierre
publicly doubted your stories and they
defended roger ailes at the time in an
interview Jeanine Pirro reportedly said
of the lawsuit this guy is doing 8
million things a day you really think
he's chasing her around I know you can't
speak about specifics but were you
prepared from the reaction from even
women that you worked with yes you were
you were yes because look at how we
react when women have the courage to
come forward we need to change this and
we are look at what's happening with the
Harvey Weinstein story you look at a
tipping point it's all that our water
good moment why because women are
putting their names and their faces to
this issue it's not just anonymity
anymore
I really believe as horrifying as those
revelations were that I'm optimistic
that the hard work I've been doing for
the last 15 months is paying off and the
gift of courage is contagious
now it passes along one woman at a time
and look where we are the hashtag me to
trending for the last two days and now
men are putting out their own hashtags
to say Jeff they want to be on board and
we need men to help us that with that
that is very important that they're a
part of this conversation there's a
great article in The Hollywood Reporter
by Christopher Navas a showrunner for
Shonda Rhimes on ABC she said this
entire culture is complicit if we make
this all about Harvey we've already lost
and I've heard many people say we're
focusing on that but please look at the
bigger picture of what is happening in
all industries do you agree with that I
agree with that because the thousands of
women who reached out to me their
stories were never told and I became a
voice for them in being able to publicly
tell my story I hope that all of those
women will find the courage and the
bravery now to also tell their stories
and that we will tell them for them to
eradicate this problem what are the
places in the workplace where they say
to tell your stories human resources but
in the book you say human resources is
sometimes not your friend you say
they're like the KGB my lawyer actually
called them that and I want to reach out
to all the human resource people who are
doing a good job and who do want to help
here we should what I advocate in the
book that there are maybe better ways to
solve this issue hire an ombudsman to
come in an independent person
who's not getting their paycheck from
possibly the harasser and also we need
to encourage more bystander training
more what bystander training what is
that people witness it do you think for
the 30 years of what was going on with
the allegations of Harvey Weinstein and
other stories people knew about it there
were enablers and the company covered it
up so we need to encourage bystanders to
also come forward but Gretchen I've
heard people say well we knew he might
have been a brood or a bully when it
came about
movies we might have known that maybe he
was a philanderer but we didn't know
that I've heard many people say we
didn't know it was that extreme and to
that you say I say that I'm sure that
other people knew that I'm sure that
they did because this is the way in
which it works and this is how we
continue to cover it up you um you
watched when when the Billy Bush tape
came out during the campaign you you
watch this with your kids why why did
you do that
well the first time I didn't watch it
with my kids I wanted to see what it was
for myself but I felt that it was
imperative that I showed my 12 and 14
year old kids that this is not how you
treat human beings and I think it was a
teaching moment for millions of parents
across America at least I hope it was
that they could show their children that
this is not how you respect women
because look it starts with our kids
young this is why I have an entire
chapter on how I believe we should
parent our kids in an equal fashion
because it's really more about our sons
how are we raising them to respect women
when they eventually get into the
workplace and that videotape I don't
care what your politics are sexual
harassment is a political and this is
why everyone should care about it when
somebody harasses you they don't say are
you a Republican or a Democrat they just
do it and this is why we should all care
about it and human decency supersedes
any political policy in my mind yes you
went forever you went through a very
rough time Gretchen was it all worth it
when you look back at it right in the
book how lonely it was sometimes you
didn't hear from people you expected to
hear from you felt alone many times as
you sit here today was it all worth it
for you to go through this it was Gail
because if there's one constant thing
about me I always take on a challenge
head-on and I never give up and I know
that I have been a voice for so many
women who never had one and now I'm
seeing that something good is coming of
this and I really hope that I can change
laws on Capitol Hill as well and get rid
of the secrecy so that we take this
issue out of the shadows and help so
many others gretchen carlson thank you
thanks for having me
miss North said really good to see you
at the
thank you proceeds from beef ears will
go to Gretchen's gift of courage fun the
book is on sale today wherever you like
to buy your books